Hi everyone, I'm Jun, founding engineer
at Tusk. I'm excited to share about a
paradigm for building the next
generation of AI interfaces, the ones
that put humans in the center,
augmenting our capabilities, and helping
us be more thoughtful and
creative. It's a collection of ideas
that I've been thinking about for a
while now. Though some of these concepts
might be a little bit more speculative,
I do hope to encourage more builders in
the space to consider these patterns and
principles. Now, it's often said that
2025 is the year of the agents and
rightfully so. From general agents
performing research and browser use for
you to deeply verticalized apps across
all industries, AI agents are everywhere
ready to offload your tasks from you.
And as agent based tooling and protocols
get more and more mature and
sophisticated is no doubt that large
chunks of knowledge work will automated
away in time to come. A lot of agents
are focused on automating discrete tasks
and for good reason. Well, it's easier
to quantify the unit of work performed
and sell the promise of eradicating
tedious and boring work that people
don't like doing. It's also easier to
benchmark the completion of these tasks
quick and quickly compare one system
against
another. But it's also not difficult to
spot the potential drawbacks of such a
future if it's not carefully managed.
Firstly, there's a notion that you know
over reliance on automating work away
breeds general laziness and atrophy of
skills. I'm sure most of you are
discerning users but when you v code an
app without thoughtful review or at
least bother to sufficiently understand
its inner workings how are you
maintaining this as a skills are you
sure you know what you're
attributing many high judgment domains
like coding and design still require
tight human supervision relying on human
experience and taste for approval a lot
of these are also like high context
tasks where it's often difficult to just
upload perfect context and encapsulate
them in prompts for accurate judgement
since a lot of them a lot of these like
live in the minds of experienced
professionals
anyway. So the main thesis of this talk
is this instead of getting humans to
accommodate to AI systems uh attempting
to automate complex tasks and doing so
suboptimally why not spend that comput
just helping humans produce high quality
work in the first place. So in this talk
I'd like to introduce some ideas for
augmentation based UX. We look at
interaction patterns for how AI can help
users review blind spots, spark
creativity, and amplify thoughtful
decision-m some principles for designing
AI products to emphasize and grow human
capabilities. Um, and trustworthy human
AI partnerships. Let me make this
concrete with a simple comparison. Um,
the automation approach to AI emails
might look like this, right? The AI
writes the entire email for you and and
sends it on your behalf. Um, you're out
of the loop. Basically the the
augmentation approach is a little bit
different. Um AI could help you u
brainstorm key points. For example,
suggest alternative phrasings. Um check
your tone. Maybe it says, "Hey, this
might come across as a bit harsh. Do you
want to soften it based on your past
emails with this person or usual writing
style?" And then you review and hit
send. Same with coding, right? With
automation, AI writes the code, creates
a pull request based on a slack message
that you have assigned to it.
Augmentation could be something like AI
reviewing your pull request and says you
might have missed this edge case. This
pattern you're using here could cause
issues on a highload. Now the difference
is that in augmentation you are still in
driver seat but you have a thinking
partner or co-pilot who can see things
that you might
miss and this cap this table captures
the the fundamental shift in this
mindset. In a nutshell, many differences
uh arise based on a shift of
responsibility of the task itself and
the relationship and our relationship
with the AI system that helps us with
these tasks. It's almost like working
with an offshore contractor versus a new
team member that we grow together with.
And if you're interested in knowing more
about this in further detail, I write
about in my blog post link below. Now,
let's get to the meat. The three core
interaction patterns. I want to start
with blind spot detection because it's
the most immediately compelling. Now,
think about it. We all have blind spots,
patterns that we can't see in our own
thinking. Uh the question for AI isn't
what do you do wrong, but what didn't
you consider as you're working on this
task. This could be temporal blind spots
like noticing you always make poor
decisions when tired on a Friday
afternoons. Um or social blind spots
flagging flagging when your technical
feedback might come across as personal
criticism. Um the key challenge is
managing that signal to noise ratio and
nudging someone or challenging their
thinking without making them feel
defensive. Um, ideally the AI should be
designed in a way that reveals something
at the right time uh when a unit of work
um can be assumed to be ready. Here's
how we implemented this at task. Now
task is an AI testing platform that
finds edge cases and bugs based on your
pull requests. When you commit your code
changes instead of just surfacing
potential bugs, we create unit tests and
actually validate them, execute them
against your your codebase test
environment and surface to you verify
issues that we can prove will cause
problems in the future. You can then
choose whether to commit these tests
alongside other passing ones into your p
request so that you know there's a extra
coverage against future regressions. One
thing we try to help make reviewing
these tests easier is also to surface
any assumptions that task is making be
it from a business or engineering
standpoint and also outline potential
fixes. Um, users can provide feedback by
clicking thumbs up or thumbs down or
explain why it's something worth
considering or not. So that task learns
from your from from your review of its
assumptions. I also like to call this
systematic pessimism. We are using AI to
systematically look through um every
symbol that has been changed finding
what could go wrong um consider second
order effects in the call stack. Even
though this is something very tedious
for humans to manually perform
effectively, especially in larger, more
complex code changes. With this pattern,
we have helped uh enterprise and growth
stage companies like deep learning AI
and team fee pay catch verified bucks in
43% of p requests and at almost a
thousand new tests in 2 months in the
blind spot detection pattern not all
suggestions are created equal. I've been
thinking about how we can manage noise
with thoughtful UX. Uh one mental model
is the novelty criticality framework and
let's again consider the code review
scenario. High novelty, high
criticality. These are critical
discoveries. Things like race conditions
that you have never encountered before.
Accidentally exposing customer data.
These deserve to interrupt you. Noy, low
criticality. These are learning moments.
Suggestions like alternative approaches,
new language features, recognizing
ineffective patterns. We might want to
present this gently as maybe as
explanable
suggestions. Low novelty, high
criticality. These are more of essential
reminders. Uh things like column bugs,
standard security checks, performance
issues might help to give clear warnings
and have a little bit more flexibility
when it comes to interruption. But we
don't have to overexlain since users
probably already know the concept. Low
novelty, low criticality. These are more
matters of polish and preference, quote
formatting, min optimizations, and
things of the nature. We want to batch
these, make them optional. The magic is
in the prioritization because people
tend to only process three or more
meaningful suggestions per review
session. This framework helps you spend
the attention budget wisely. The second
pattern is cognitive partnership. Moving
from stateless answering machines to
systems that adapt to your mental
models, right? This means building a
theory of mind about users. Not just
knowing what they want, but how they
think. Do they learn through analogies?
Do they prefer visual explanations? Do
they prefer to sleep on it or prefer
like rapid iteration? Um, imagine a code
editor that learns your refactoring
patterns and proactively suggests
similar improvements in new contexts or
or a research assistant that understands
whether you synthesize information
chronologically or
automatically. The challenge here is
building this personalization without
being creepy. Um, users need to feel
understood but not
surveyed. And the third pattern,
proactive guidance, is probably the
hardest to get right. Um, the challenge
isn't knowing what to suggest but when.
Um, and great proactive guidance feels
like serendipity, not interruption. It's
like having a calendar app that suggests
meeting time is based on your energy
patterns and not just availability. A
writing tool that notices when you're
stuck and suggest taking a break rather
than pushing through. And the key is
finding that Goldilock zone, right? We
don't want to be too reactive. We also
don't be too overwhelming. Just right.
Now, let's shift gears into principles
for designing augmentative AI because
without trust, none of this matters.
How? So how do we build that trust in
these augmentation systems? Trust
becomes uh particularly crucial in
augment uh augmentation interfaces
because the relationship between human
and AI is more collaborative than
transactional. Right? Again think about
how to humans begin to trust each other
in augmentation paradigm especially
cognitive partnerships. It's likely that
we see human AI interact more like
humanto human interaction. I believe
trust needs to be progressive contextual
and biirectional. Progressive in a sense
that it's easier to build trust with low
stake suggestions before moving to high
impact decisions. um let a system prove
itself um on small things first. Trust
is also contextual um because we trust
people differently across different
domains and for different situations. So
the same should apply to AI. AI might be
brilliant at code reviews but terrible
at design feedback or you might not have
the right or sufficient context to make
certain decisions. So let's make that
transparent and birectional because true
partnership means both parties adapt.
The AI learns your preferences while you
learn its capabilities. It should adjust
its behavior based on how much you trust
it in different
scenarios. For AI to augment users, it
implies facilitating some sort of skill
growth. Automation interfaces that stay
static, augmentative AI that helps you
learn should also evolve with you. This
means some sort of skill visualization
showing people their growth, their
growing expertise over time, and
graduated complexity, right? Like
unlocking or adapting features as
competence increases or shifting
explanation patterns based on a user's
understanding over time. The goal is
genuine skill enhancement, not just the
illusion of it. Um, users should feel
themselves getting better um at their
core work and derive joy from
self-improvement, even though it may be
hard at first, not just more being more
dependent on
AI. Um, and a little note about um
product metrics. If you truly care about
your users, you should track how they're
growing as they use your product beyond
traditional engagement or usage metrics,
even though they are important as well.
Um, I think a lot of learning apps, for
example, focus on user retention and
engagement, but are users actually
improving themselves and getting more
and more capable in real life
situations. It's hard to say. So, why
does this matter? Beyond a normative
argument that AI should serve to make
people better. Well, three main reasons.
First, building an emotional connection.
AI products that make an effort to learn
from users and fulfill intellectual
needs build stickier relationships.
Chatg's memory feature is a great
example. People love feeling understood
across multiple chat sessions. Second,
long-term value. Buyers increasingly
care not just about productivity but
capability building. Can this tool make
my team not just faster but better? Um,
thirdly, as consumers, we should be more
intentional about how we learn alongside
these AI tools. We are investing our
precious time using them. So, let's make
sure we're growing, not just
grinding. As we come to the end of this
talk, I'd just like to summarize what we
have walked through so far. Um,
technological revolutions have seemed to
always been focused on efficiency. For
AI though, um, I'm particularly excited
because never had humanity advanced a
piece of technology to a point where it
can help us think better, amplify our
intuition, taste, and
creativity. This may take the form of
blind spot detection, cognitive
partnerships, and proactive guidance.
And to get there, we need to invest in
better UX that enable high trust,
thoughtful agency, and learn alongside
users. I think the most profound
technologies don't just replace humans.
They unlock what makes us uniquely
human. The next decade won't be about AI
doing our work, but AI helping us think
in ways that we couldn't before. What's
transformative isn't just making us more
productive. It's about making us more
thoughtful and more aware of our
cognitive patterns like mirrors for our
minds, showing us blind spots and
suggesting perspectives that we
habitually miss. And no doubt we are
still at the starting line of
understanding how to build these
systems. But the core insight that
technology should enhance rather than
replace human capability will remain
true even as our understanding evolves
and the future belongs to interfaces
that help us uh become more fully human
not less. With that, thank you for
listening and let's stay connected,
continue your conversation.